各位屏幕前的同学,各位塑教术的从业者们,大家好,我是国庆中间数字科技有限公司的研发总监,农生海。
欢迎大家来到影视计算线上目课第3期。
今天这个案例分享我不想只是泛泛儿潭的巨甲概念,而是想带大家深入的医疗大数据的深水区,
利用可行数据空间技术去真正的在数据要数流通领域进行项目实践。
那么在整个课程开始之前,我希望在座的各位,特别是那些接触过医院信息和医疗信息工作的开发者,
回想一下大家在医院或者医疗行业重验一些场景,特别是在针对区域对接医院里面的HIS、PMR、PSAS以及LIS等等这些系统。
它里面有着全员的挂号、收费、D组、组数、限并式、手速记录、CT、核实公正、这些影像文件,动不动就是PB,或者说是甚至并高。
在我们的HIS系统里面,经常会有用Oracle和Setshare,甚至有些医院会去做一些Nest系统里面做一些像Cast这种数据库。
它都是比较面向于医疗医疗这可能也非常好用的,但是不利于整合成流通的这种数据库。
那么在这20年,以前的20年,我们国内的医疗行业真的是充分完成了新积化建设。
我们是成功的把业务流程搬进了这些系统,实现了不足华办公,或者轻足华办公。
那么时至今日,我们去谈数据要素的时候,这些系统却变成了一个个棘手的严重。
HIS的系统出去了,PACS领向AI进不来,这些高价值的数据就像是被锁在了保险柜里面的金条,我们看得到用不了,或者能用又不敢用。
那么这一期为大家进行分享的主要就是四个方向,从我们现状的通领和需求,以及我们的基础价购品型设计,以及实战的案例和名词解释进行一个分享。
我们首先讲一下现状,首先国家从2023年国数据就已经成立,而且24年也是年底时候发布了可行数据空间发展成的报告。
国家的信号非常冷却,数据必须流动起来,未来除了医疗、金融这些,只要是数据,那就是由数据激动。
无论是AI制药、医保控费,还是流行病的预测,都需要打破这些孤岛。
那么问题来了,虽然要建设100个以上可行数据空间,形成一批数据空间解决方案和最佳事件,
但是怎么再不动摇HIS、PSS、现有的业务系统稳定性的情况下,我们安全的把这些数据拿出来用,
同时保证数据的隐私性、脱敏性、安全性以及合规性。
那么这个就是我们今天主要去讲的可行数据空间,怎么和咱们一样进行实际的落地实践。
那么我们这个详细续再颇息一下,为什么医疗数据流通这么烂,难道真的只是技术不行吗?
那我们刚刚说了,我们的这个整个医疗行业的信息发现是非常的完善,那为什么还会说技术不行,那肯定就是,
说那是因为什么呢?那是因为有合规利益技术构成的不可能删奖,导致了医院与医院之间,或者机构与医院之间,
甚至于这个医保局,或者说会见委,这些机构之间导致的这个管辖所有以及主因素等等去考虑了。
首先是不敢开放,为什么我这个要写,不愿不敢,不会。首先我先说不敢,医疗数据是因为包含了隐私基因各种数据的,
它是数据安全法和个人兴趣保护法的平线,那么为什么是不敢,你如果是一个医院的院长,或者兴趣各主任,
一家要求说,你把你的这个M2库倒给我,我去那个大模型,你也不敢给啊,因为传统的数据交付,就是意味着数据靠背,一旦数据靠出医院,就失去了控制。
他被复制了多少份,卖给了谁,给谁用了,给谁看,你完全不知道,这种风险,谁都担不起,
而且因为网络安全保护法,数据安全保护法,个人信息保护法,它都是已经明确了我们针对于数据的监控监管,
所以说,从原则上,很多数据没办法共同共享流通。
再一个就是不愿意开发,因为我这个收集了很多数据,然后这个怎么去用数据,收集数据的这个医院或者说医院委啊,这种组织单位去考虑的。
那我在用的过程中,肯定要考虑到一些数据开发啊,或者说数据产生的价值这些,那总不能说成为活类风嘛,对吧,那不会开发,这是什么,技术必领。
因为技术必领是什么,就是我们现在的各种系统建设了很多啊,包括有些数据中台尝试去解决这个问题,但是还是会出现一个问题,系统必够性。
A医院的CD2系统还没建好,B医院的系统用的是10年前的HIS系统,数据标准不一,而且接口是千万块的。
你想在物理上把它汇聚到一个大十字名清洗,它的工程量大,而且不安全,同时也会一定能解决,对吧。
所以说,技术有一定的必领,但它不是必要的,但是它一定是存在的,那我们怎么去解决呢?
首先,还是回到这个刚刚说的,关于这个数据开发的问题,因为这个利益分配的问题,那数据开发就会是一个空谈与不空谈的一个概念,
因为你不去解决利益分配问题,你就没办法去做数据开发,就像我刚刚解决的这个数据作为医院作为数据的生产者,
它是从病的患者,包括医生那里付出到的数据,那么拿到这个数据之后,你不解决这个数据的价值问题和数据的安全问题,
那你凭什么去用这个数据呢?或者开发这个数据呢?那其实核心就是,如果是无常的提供数据,医院承担了隐私泄漏的雷,那医院是不答应的。
那同理,企业或者是政府部门也不愿意,那就一定要有一个能够精准去济粮济费,让医院从活泪风变成了合伙人,让这个政府部门能够有票的进行监管。
同时呢,让这个企业能够合理的去使用,合理安全的去使用这些数据,才能去进行数据开发。
同时数据开发它是一个需要由技术,数据,政策,资本,多个资源去协同的一个过程,它不是一个空谈。
所以说我们得先解决利率分配,才能说数据开发,才能说我们刚刚说的三个点去解决。
那么可行数据空间恰好就能解决这个利益开发问题,那其实核心就是可行数据空间的五方嘛,对吧。
这个我们的这个使用方,运营方,生产方,监管方和服务方,这个下来有一个,呃,需求的一个明确定义吧,到时候,大家会去看一下名字也是。
那么解决了一个核心矛盾之后,我们就可以去大师的去畅想,可行数据空间怎么去做。
首先,医疗数据的流通怎么去做,那么我们可以说这个构建的可行数据空间,那可行数据解决的是什么?
我们要去构建一套三权分制的数字发期约,就是我们将数据资源持有权加工权与经营前进行详细的分配。
比如说持有权是我们通过技术保持物理上的永远留在医院的本地服务器里面,一步都不会离开,也就是数据可用不可接。
那么,加工权是什么?就是使用方,它获得了这个数据的技术案的能力,通过以直技术案或者说数据杀箱形式拿到了数据,并且在使用数据,但是它是不可接数据的。
它不知道数据实际是什么样的,它可能只知道你给我的数据物录里面有一个姓名,有一个姓名,然后我再去使用。
同时,这个经营权就是留加工方,对吧,或者说一个资源合约去建立起,他们说谁合理去分配有一个利益,那怎么去分配?
它是通过这个机制保障授权,或者是怎么回约去保障,正常说的数据商品怎么去使用?
那么我们就充分的解决,刚刚说的不可能三角,首先是安全问题,也有的是通过这个用量法或者说是杀箱法的形式,甚至以实际算了,那原始数据是不会出狱的。
同时呢,数据是按照数据安全的无法进行,数据脱敏和数据加密,就能保障个人敏感数据不泄漏,同时原始数据不泄漏。
那么在使用方看来就是,我不用担心数据和释放这个来源合规,或者说释放真是可靠,因为数据都在我这个采购的数据所有方案本地,那可能是医院,可能是衛健委等等。
所以说数据来源是可以保证,数据质量也是可以保证的。
那我们这里也可以后续会讲一个中设概念,就是我们可以去用一些最小的样子数据完成中设。
同时呢,我们作为政府部门,能够去完成可信可监管,因为你所有的流程都在我们这个可信费工间服务品来里面去产生的。
所以说你肯定就离不开我们的神经知识。
那这里我讲一下我们实战过程中怎么去做的结束架构与选情。
这个部分比较硬核,请各位同学打起精神来。
首先我们构建的中间,底层主要依赖两个结束选情。
第一个资助是什么?就是我们要去构建一套TE可行资金环境,因为医疗行业,虽然说我们刚刚说了通过这种类似于容器或者说网络隔离的形式做这些。
它依旧不一定很好,但是你如果使用这个TE的这种计算硬件环境去做的话,它就是相当可靠的。
因为你就算是超级系统管理员,你不一定能够看到它的一些数据过程。
那你可以把TE理解成一个配合或者非地。
当这个医院的past系统的数据被读入内存基因计算的时候,拥有肉图全新的超级系统管理员,
它也没办法去窥谈里面的内存数据,因为这是硬件级别的强硬值保护。
那我们可以看到从任务管理员之后到任务会跟踪调度,照我们的数据清醒到出来,最终变成一个算法服务,相对外服务。
或者说给它一个算法服务结果,比如说我想知道这个医院里面有没有这么个人。
OK,我只会告诉你有或没有。
所以说原始数据就没有出于。
那在计算过程里面是不可被这个篡改或监控的。
那我们所有的流程都会在算法服务里面被记录起来。
所以说这是第一个选刑,我们使用可行时间环境。
第二个选刑是什么?
我们要去考虑这个跨域管控,也就是什么?数据员适配。
那刚刚说了,我们有这个Oracle,MySQL,甚至它可能会用大数据来的,比如Hem,或者Habase,甚至Hadob,对吧?
或者是非关系的,甚至MangoDB,甚至医院还有很多的影像数据,比如说PSS影像。
那这些都是要去做跨域的这种,或者说数据员的适配的服务的,整就做。
那么我们可以通过原始数据的可行的这种生分战证,通过跨域计算,完成了一系列,然后说类似于TE的这种V台交往,完成了我们的衍生数据使用。
这也是一个我们的资助。
那整体,我们怎么去设计?
首先我讲一下,我们整个可行数据员服务平台的业务设计,是按照数标委,出去的可行数据员技术标准去做的整体架构。
当然,根据行业业务不同,我们也可以去加不同的行业业务的一些需求。
这里是直接贴了一个完整的,比较标准。
我们可以看到可行数据空间服务平台,也就是可行数据员员要功能节点。
空间服务平台连接器三者构成,那么构成过后,通过互联互通协议,统一,三统一码,生分标识目录,
三统一完成生分管理,连接器管理,目录管理,以及我们的诱节链管理等等,这一系列服务平台的有能力了,向上的一个全新统一。
其实核心统一的什么?首先是生分,标识目录,以及纯正省级,也就是可监管,可监控。
那么这些东西都有统一的,说明它就不能造假,因为它就像我们用去派链比先说的,它是一个去中心化,但是我们目前可行数据空间服务平台不是去中心化,
但是它是使用的联盟链的形式,因为它有一个中心嘛,但是中心能够做统一监管,在过程中,其他的平台类似于其他中心节点,
其实也是中心节点,区域节点,到你的平台的节点,那么我们的可行数据空间目前按照网标识分成了城市级,行业级,企业级,个人和跨境。
那么一样的,它有一些通过无分连互通,能够完成这一系列的操作,所以说在监管方面就非常安全了。
那对于实际的数据情况方、数据生产方,它通过连接器,将自己的数据员揭露进来,通过互联互通网关请求完成身份主体认证和有节点认证之后,就不能进行数据产品的生产加工,去管理自己的一些计量存费啊这些。
那么我们接下来就详细去讲一下什么,就是我们这个在实战过程中怎么去做的整个可行数据空间的有架构。
那么我们可以看到,从上一场就是刚刚说的第三方的可行数据空间,或者行业区域的功能节点,都是相当于我们自己建设完之后,一定是要和全国的精神打通关。
因为可行数据空间分成两种,一种是概念型的可行数据空间,一种是技术型的可行数据空间。
那么概念型的就是形成了一个联盟或者是一个行业现象,大家都按照这个统一的标准来,你接入进来就是可行数据空间。
但技术上怎么去保证可行,是今天我主要为大家就分享的好。
那这都是这个旁标,我就不需要去详细讲,这些大家按照这个标准去做,一定就能满足国家级标准。
那么我们主要讲我们的密带计算和隐私计算。
首先密带计算,我们通过银语的也就是说银识计算的一些技术,比如说银识,就叫银银查学运动方案、安全学习。
还有我们银语提供的这些方架,我们就完成一系列的包括从大数引擎、数据不引擎、基础引擎去完成的生装,变成了一个计算顺应。
那么我们通过连接器的介入就能将我们的身份以及我们的一些银识计算扩展全部关联起来。
我们可以看到这个价格,从我们的直接和这个口气数据不引擎的对接都是从我们连接器的互联互装上移。
然后进来之后我们可以通过这个密带的扩展,然后完成实际计算,然后将数据进入到我们的这个对应的目录也好。
比如说用了这个运营中心里面的成品和约这些去。
那么我们整个标准就是围绕这个我们的安全体系进行的。
首先我们可以看到这个安全体系里面分的分级,这是根据国家数据安全保护法,然后以及数据的一个加密透明标准去完成这一系列的处理。
所以说安全体系是非常重要的,其实就是我们整个密带和隐私之外的这两个概念,这是整个价格图。
那我们刚刚讲完之后我们就讲一下我们的数据流向吧。
首先这个数据流向是什么?
数据流向就是指的我们的数据从这个数据提供方到数据生产方到数据这个服务方,
这三方的一个整体流向方式。
我们可以看到这里有一个数据资源管理平台,那么从采集治理编目按需授权到资源申请产品发开发成为三价生命登记产命交易完整的一个数据流向的一个指向。
像这一边一般是数据提供方它去准,那这一边一般是数据服务方去准,
然后这一边就是数据运放,这也是数据运放,也就是三方。
那你也可以同时是具备三方能力的,你可以自己去采集治理编目收权,然后就做一些,那一般是三方。
那么提供方就需要将自己的数据员,比如说你建立数据中台,你就可以拿过来使用。
然后你通过社会数据,或者你外部数据引入,通过你的数据资源词打通我们的连接器,将你的数据揭露连接器之后,
你就可以和可情数据方面服务平台进行数据的一个共通,就打通了。
就像这个我把资源词放这儿了,接了个水管过来了,但是水管的流量大小都是由数据提供方的连接器可以去做管理的。
或者说你能在你自己的数据服务平台里面去管理连接器的这个流量。
那么这里别人去想使用你的资源就必须就使用申请。
如果使用自己的那就不需要额外的资源申请。
那产品开发完之后通过运营系统和说技术的这种开发应用,变成模型也好,变成数据目录也好,数据产品也好,你都需要通过数据资产的去全登记,这样你的数据资源才能合法化。
然后再提供给外部进行流通,进行比如说产品中心也好,公署中心也好,进行数据产品交易。
这么个过程,全流程数据都可以被计量,都可以被监控监管,同时至少是被存证的。
所以说这个流向是非常重要的。
那么我讲完数据流向之后,我们就要去着重去讲一下我们的核心,核心数据中间的连接器。
首先我们讲连接器就必须得谈连接器是干什么的。
在实际工程落地里面,连接器通常会部署在哪?
一般是部署在DMZ区的隔离区,或者前阵机上,它就像一个网关,或者说像我们现实的历史就像海关一样。
你这个什么过来不管你内网还是外网交付,你都必须过来这。
你内网的数据和外网的数据都拦下来在这个平台进行,
比如说数据管理、定单的管理,还有我对外开放的杀箱的,或者影子计算的这种服务的管理,对吧。
我要不去保证你的身份搞信,给你整个所有输去的日子和进来的日子的记录,比几乎这个连接器的一群算来监管。
那么我们核心就是通过网络控制介入,到使用控制引擎,到杀箱的整体管理进行的处理。
那么我们的杀箱管理主要做什么就是保证数据、计算都必须在我们的杀箱里面,绝不允许一出。
所有的行为都是在这个我们可控的范围内,原始数据永远是在提供方本定,而不会到这个使用方或者是服务方甚至运营方。
那么我们就能保证数据可用,却不可见,原始数据不会出于这个过程。
那么我们讲完这个连接器之后,我们就讲连接器这个技术是怎么去设计的。
首先我们看到左边的这个连接器,我们假设它是A1,右边的连接器2,我们假设它是B1。
他们中间怎么进行的这个通讯,然后是通过的密集态计算数据。
那么我们把这个连接器像洋冲一样拨开,我们去看一下里面到底有什么。
首先我们从顶层设计上是给他们提供的一个API Gateway,比如网关嘛。
那么通过健全、全链路等一个追踪监控所有指标,那这一步是干什么?
就是我们去做到每一个计算请求是谁发起的,什么时候发起的,耗时是多少都会被击入。
那对应的日子会进行日子上报到服务平台,一层一层往上报。
所以说整个数据使用过程和加工过程甚至智力过程都是可被监控,可被这个落地的。
然后同时呢,我们中间去做了个什么?
SEALGIRLUP,我们做了一个GROPE,不好意思,SEALGROPE,我们做了一个业务服务产。
我们通过合约,通过工作流编排,通过计量的形式,去将我们的数据管理的这种法律条款进行代码化,
也就是说这个各个行业的这个规则,我们在合约里面订跑。
那么工作流排版,也是由我们现有的行业业务进行编排。
那么计量说白了就是模型跑了多少的CPU,或者调用多少算力,使用多少数据,都是有账单记录的。
那么最后的底层我们做了什么?我们做了一个执行代理,这就是这个言语真正发挥作用的地方。
我们可以看到我们使用了这个sweety flow,PIR,还有这个,我们用了一些这个言语现有的嘛,
比如说刚刚说的影子计算,影子求交,还有连帮学习。
但是所有的交互过程都是在哪,都是在我们这个连接器进行处理的,
也就是我们在实际数据的一个加工,或者资本过程中,都是以连接器对连接器。
那么在连接器对连接器的时候,它不是通过什么去做的,它们是通过数据密带托管到密带计算数据里面去做的,
也就是有Tea,有个说用密带的一个交囊去做,也就是刹箱嘛。
那么我们不管怎么去做这些计算之后,所有的服务部署啊这些都是通过什么计划,
其实核心也是为了保证连接器在医院的市有源泼的物理机上能够快速被拉起,弹性的去扩容而已。
所以说通过这个图,大家应该就明白了,所谓科学数据部件是在物理上由一个个部署在医院的连接器通过我们可信数据员服务品来的互联网程的完成了一系列加密网络的构建,
然后同时是在一个大水池里面,你有你的,我有我的,我们在一个大水池里面进行处理,
或者我们两个大水池的时间,加了一个水管进行一个合理控制,在这个水管控制呢,
我们有一个第三方会去做合理的监管,包括我们日制和约的签署和我们水上的登记等等。
那么我们是怎么去做的这个隐私计算和杀相的平台设计呢?
首先在数据杀相上面,我们要考虑到一个可实化开发工具和一个可执行环境的工具。
那么可实化开发工具,我们是用的3D load,啊,同时,可因数据环境的用适kbs,
我们直接能够通过可实化的形式进行代表编辑,比如PY脚本啊,或者sego的啊,这些。
隐私计算其实也是一样的,只是说更多用了你现有的一些技术,比如说原来学学啊,
或者说我们借助了一些大模型的,历代模型的处理啊。
那其实不管是怎么样,啊,我们可以在用现有的一些技术条件,
基于引语这个给我们行使的一些基础,进行更好的应用开发。
那我们刚刚说完了我们整个技术架构,我们就做的,那我们就讲一下实战的一些案例。
刚说了很多话,就是大家一定想知道这个东西怎么用,啊,这个东西架构是架构,
我们说了很多架构上的事情,你们是怎么做的,怎么去做的,然后怎么去实际落地啊,
那我们可以看到这里,我们需要去训练一个这个费结合辅助整段的模型。
那怎么去做的,我们通过A院和B医院的一个票数啊,这里简单讲一下,
A医院它的PSS系统里面有大量CT影像,但是还缺少很多病理区局,
但是B医院呢,它恰恰有,是总流装费有很多的详细的病理诊经标准,
但是它没有多少的这个影像床链,啊,传统的做法就是将数据拷贝到硬盘里面能够快递,
这个东西很违规,而且低效。他们怎么去完成的这个联邦一个建模呢,
我们是给他们部署了英语的P2P,然后构建了一个可行数据工间,
科研人员能够在平台上发起任务,也就是我们这里看到的,啊,他在Seer上发来个任务,
然后将联邦学习广入模型下发给A和B,还有Clinic1和Clinic2,
然后他们进行这个连接系列给连接,连接完之后,他们就在自己的Clinic1和Clinic2训练这个模型,
他有A和B的数据,他们训练完之后,中间去交换模型结果,
这也就是联邦学习嘛,然后刚刚说了他是基于英语的整个做就做,
所以说我们能拿到对应的模型更新,最终由Seer和B将T度模型,啊,
这个或者说最终的模型参数共享给Clinic1和Clinic2,
他们拿到了最后的全局模型,这个过程中啊,他会重复十几轮甚至几百轮,啊,直到模型收敛完成进行下放,
最后呢,他就能通过我们刚刚说的可行数据空间或者说通过联邦学习甚至以实际算完成了,
这个大模型或者说一个影像模型的一个建模,那么A和B的医院都还在自己的啊,本地在Clinic,
像在自己的保险里面一样安全,那么同样他还可以用于药物研发,流行病分析和疾病预测,
甚至基金联合,那我们讲一下第二个就是院内数据的一个整合,我们帮助了多个三方医院还有医保办,
去完成了一些这个数据的整合和公共数据运营,首先我这里说一下就是具体场景,
这医保办呢,他想做控肺分析,啊,病领和想去做科研,那么医保数据是在HIS系统的社会表里,
那病领数据是在HIS的这个这个系统的报表里,报告表里面,然后系统他肯定是不同的,甚至他们数据库也是用的不一样的,
一个是用的住院号,一个是用的调号,他这个东西是完全不同的,那怎么形成不同呢?
我们去通过影视球交,啊,通过身份证号,拿到这个对你的数据关联,也就是一个拿到一个水雨,算出HIS和LIS系统的胶值,
也就是说又做了这个,又做了院,又做了病理检查的病人,啊,你拿到这个数据之后,然后去做联合分析嘛,
也就是我们的SEQL,啊,我们做了这个之后,去计算他的这个病理和住院天罪以及他的费用情况,完成了我们这一系列的一个壁坏,
通过Agent的直接数据统计结论,让我们的这个两个科室,啊,医保办和这个科室主任互相拿到自己想要的,
整个全程他不需要共享任何一个数据库,在物理意义上还是各做各的,原始数据也在本地,也没有数据卸任的风险,
那所以说,在整个领域的价格体系,啊,我们不管是用于可行数工间实践,还是用于一些实际的,啊,快速开发效应,或者项目的实战,都是能够很快,那么去解决了,
那么最后,我做个总结,哈,我们刚刚从通点出发,猜狗的这个架构,然后去跑那个实战,我希望大家记住三个关键时,一个是可行数据空间,那什么是可行数据空间,建我这里的名字解释一,啊,
然后另一个是连接器,那什么是连接器,建我这里面的名字解析二,那整个领域啊,是解决了我们刚刚说的关于密台数据价密的数据问题,
所以说大家也可以下来多去试试,最后给屏幕前的各位一点建议,如果你是高校学生,不要只盯着数据上的算法,
去领域参加社区,跑通一个psi的demo,去理解一下什么叫提铸交换,什么是影视气球交流,比什么都来得快,
但如果你是医疗行业的从业者,你规划明年的预算,就不要光只想再买,存储买服务器,可以思考一下,
如何通过部署连接器,可行数据空间,构建可行数据空间服务平台,把成税在多个医院的这种系统,
就是hass跟数据的例子那些系统,里面的数据变成数据资产,去负能科研,去创造价值,医疗数据的未来,
不存在于拥有多少数据,而在于能连接多少数据,很高兴今天能够跟大家分享这些,
希望这堂课能够通往至于空间的一把钥匙,让你们能够真正的实验录顶,
谢谢大家的观看,我们下次再见。